ああああああああぁぁぁぁぁあ！！
こんにちわはじめしゃちょーです
みなさんはぁ
部屋
好きですか？
僕ですねぇ、
部屋が大好きなんですよ。
部屋というものは、人にとって特別な空間
自分だけの居場所
車の中とかって、すごいなんか、自分だけの部屋みたいな
一人暮らしも自分だけの部屋っ！
実家にもない、自分だけの、
部屋。
秘密基地とか作りませんでした？
そうゆう感覚なんですよ
なんかこう自分だけの部屋も欲しいなと思ったんですけども
ネットで見てたら組み立てられる部屋みたいのがあったので買ってみました
こちらです
なにあ、ともあれクソでっかいっすね。
なんか、閉じこもることのできる 部屋が
欲しいんですよ、小さい
閉鎖空間が一つ欲しいなって思ってぇ
この部屋ねぇ、結構広いんですよ！
ガラッとしてて
あれをねぇ、ここら辺にねぇこう、デゥンって
ここら辺に大きな部屋を作りたいんですよ、
でな！皆！驚かずにきいてくれ！
この部屋なんとぉ！
段ボールで出来てるみたいです
それなりに、しっかりした部屋が作れるっぽいんでぇ
今日ですね、はじめアミューズメントパークに
もう一つ！！新しい部屋を作りたいと思います。
では行こうっ！
大先輩に
えいっ。
作っていきます。
でも、(外装の)作りが全く分からん。
待って、
デカすぎん？
待って、こんなにでかいって聞いてないぞ。
これ、まじででかいじゃん。
とりあえず、開けます。
待って、本当にでかいな、これ。
これを組み立てていくわけか。ちょっと、見てみましょう。
なんか、簡単って書いてあった気がするんだよな。
(これは)要らない。
これも要らない。
これも要らないのかな?
おお!  おお!!  おお!!!
これを開けて部屋に入るみたいな感じかな?
やばい、やばい。
これは絶対ドアなんだよな。
ドア確保。
ここに来てようやく説明書だ!
個人的ダンボール防音室
"だんぼっち"
どんだけ大声出しても
大丈夫なんじゃねーか説があるんですけど。
手順がですねー
余裕だな、すぐ出来そう。
10個で出来る、パーッとやっちゃいましょう!
"床パネルを最初に置きます"ですって。
ヤベぇなマジでほんとに
でかすぎてやばい。
ここからなんですけど、
床パネルー?
これの気がするんですよね。
こうやって、ここに置いてー
こう組み立てていくみたいなイメージだと思うんですけど、
多分これで挿していけば出来る気がするんすよね。
やばい、
これ1人だと無理なやつっすね...
必ず二人以上で組み立ててくださいって書いてある。
たっちーー！
たっち: 赤ちゃんくさくないすか?
もう一息です。
やばい、テンション上がってきた、
てか速いっすよ、
1時間かかってないです、作るの。
よし、
はい、というわけで完成ー
ーと思いきや、まだ天井が残っていました。
あとここですね、ここだけです。
天井要らない気がしてきたんだけど。
全然暗いじゃないですか、これ、だって。
100%暗いじゃん。
はい、というわけで、
天井もネジをつけなきゃいけないんですけども、
なんか暗そうなんで、
取り外しがいつでもできるようにこのままにしておきます。
完成!
はい、というわけで完成しました。
あのー、
すげー
じゃ・・・
いや、邪魔とは言いませんが場所を取りますね。
もう、この部屋がほぼ、なんか、
すげー狭くなっちゃったように感じます。
まあ、それもありでしょう。
でかいんですけど、ゲーム実況とか出来そうかな
って思ってるんですよ、僕は。
防音でしょ、だって。
ちょっと、中に入ってみましょう。
はい!
行きます。
おお!
まって、暗っ!
極めて暗いぞ。
天井ぶち開けたほうがいいな。
一応無かったら無かったでなー
開けると大体これぐらいの明るさになります。
ていうわけで、ここにこうやって、
パソコンとか置いたら編集したり、
勉強とかもここでできるっていう感じです。
これダンボールの中ですけど、結構広いですよ。
全然ー
動かせる、体が
うわー、これ迷うなー、天井つけるかどうか。
暗くなるから
中に照明も付けなきゃいけなくなるんですけど。
普通にテンションが上がる、嬉しい！
だんぼっち、テンション上がるんですけど、
今後、ゲーム実況とか個室で何か使うときとかに、
使えればいいかなと思っております。
めっちゃ嬉しい!
けど部屋がー